joining me now is retired army officer
General Sir Richard Sheriff who formally
served as NATO's Deputy Supreme Allied
Commander Europe General thank you very
much for being with us and I just want
to pick up on what the U.S defense
secretary said he wants to see which is
Russia weakened militarily so they can't
do anything like this again for that to
happen doesn't that require a more
substantial NATO involvement in all this
uh well good evening to you and uh and I
I I I in essence I I think he's
absolutely right Lloyd Iceland is
absolutely right to see uh say that he'd
like to see a week in Russia I think
we'd all like to see a week in Russia
and a Russia that is not capable of
inflicting the Unspeakable things that
it is doing on Ukraine
um I guess the question is how you get
there
um and the first point to make is the
need for NATO to continue and perhaps
take more risk particularly when it
comes to providing the sort of support
heavier Weaponry indirect combat support
and the like to help the ukrainians do
what they need to do to blunton and
weaken the Russian offensive in donbass
and elsewhere
right and a NATO former NATO a U.S
general rather was suggesting that a
more NATO involvement could mean some
sort of humanitarian Mission getting
involved in some sort of humanitarian
Mission more forcefully
yes General free Phil Breedlove who I I
know well
um as uh he was my my sacker when I was
the besacker so we we go back a long way
together and I think he's absolutely
right the caveat I would say is this
number one for NATO to do anything in
Ukraine means that and indeed for NATO
to take more risk means that NATO has
got to be prepared for the worst case
and the worst case of course is war with
Russia so this would become something
much bigger than it is already and and
NATO needs to adopt a mindset frankly uh
that that is going to be the that could
be the case and therefore it needs to
prepare for that eventuality I think the
second point I'd make is that there's no
such thing as being half in half out
you're either in if you if and if if
NATO did decide to go down that route of
providing humanitarian assistance and
indeed providing protection to Odessa
which is what he also said that would
mean a NATO force to protect any
humanitarian effort on the ground and as
far as the Russians are concerned that
would be an act of War NATO would be in
uh so NATO's got to go in Eyes Wide Open
um with a clear State clear clear
understanding of where it wants to get
to and a strategy to get there and a
strategy to manage the risks of getting
that and they chose a long way short of
being able to do that sort of thing it
comes back brings us back to my first
point about NATO being ready for the
worst case which is going to require a
fundamental mindset change across the
alliance as a whole
yeah and general Richard Barons was
suggesting last week that NATO was not
ready or prepared to get involved in a
war with Russia do you
think he's right
uh well he's right in the sense that
it's absolutely not ready frankly the
NATO effort thus far in terms of
reinforcing the Eastern flank of the
alliance uh has been pretty Curative
good in Parts in the sense that the the
NATO response Force has moved uh they've
got 40 000 troops on that border but
that is nothing like enough to present
the sort of cast iron solid deterrent
capability uh that is going to overmatch
the Russians uh if NATO wants to take
risk which I believe it should do in
terms of being prepared well that is
going to require the consensus of 30
individual member states of NATO and
that takes time to achieve um and you
have as I've said elsewhere NATO's can
only move at the speed of the slave ship
in the Convoy but ultimately if the the
case is made the Leverage is in is is is
is is is is is is taken and and put on
the put on the allowance by the leader
of the plants the United States NATO
could well get that
and if NATO doesn't get involved more
substantially does Putin in your view
end up winning this war a person if NATO
does not get involved more substantially
I I suspect that ultimately no one will
win this War I don't think the
ukrainians and you're the man on the
ground I'm sitting back in my
comfortable armchair yes I salute you
for being a man on the ground I suspect
the ukrainians will find it difficult to
generate the sort of combat power uh and
offensive maneuver capability in order
to throw the Russians out of Ukraine
even with significant support in terms
of weapons
um from from the alarms on the other
side of the the equation I think the
Russians by all accounts appear to have
been significantly written down uh as
they've demonstrated when they were
defeated in the battle for Kiev that
that their capability their combined
arms capability the inability to
dominate the air and win their battle uh
their failure of logistics and above all
their atrocious failures of morale uh
has meant them falling back on the
destruction of of cities uh together
with the associated gasliness of the war
crimes and criminal and and mass rapes
that we I'm afraid are seeing too much
of
um so I think this could well degenerate
into a long bloody war of attrition uh
with and the only way to break that I
think is for NATO to ramp up support for
the ukrainians
and I mean just the last question a
minute or so left where does Putin stop
do you think where does he end this
there will be no peace in Europe while
Putin is in the Kremlin he wants to
eliminate Ukraine and he has already
said he wants to bring all Russian
speakers under the banner of Russian but
Mother Russia which must place the
Baltic states in his Target area
and so NATO I think has to recognize we
in the west have to recognize uh that
Putin will not stop any form of
ceasefire will just give him the means
give him the break he needs to try and
reorganize uh re-re regain the
initiative and start all over again and
so the the strategy has got to think
through be thought through how best can
peace be um be guaranteed in Europe in
the long term and I think two aspects
number one is weak on the Russians as
Lloyd Austin has said number two is that
NATO is going to have to provide that
Ultimate Security guarantee across the
whole of Europe including probably one
day Ukraine
okay General Sheriff thank you very much
indeed
thank you very much Cindy for having me